Prof: Good morning
everyone.
We are on the cusp of
Valentine's Day.
So I thought it was appropriate
for us all to tell Rome how much
we love--Rome or Roma--how much
we love her.
And so I've done that here.
I've loved Rome for as long
as--for a long time,
certainly from the age that you
are now.
And I know that there are many
of you in this class who feel
the same way,
and I hope that those of you
who entered this class,
without having those strong
feelings for Rome,
have come to love the city and
its civilization as much as I
do.
So this is a kind of Valentine
lecture, for Rome.
And I think that the particular
topic that it is,
is appropriate,
in the sense that we are going
to be looking at a number of
quite eclectic monuments today,
very different monuments,
one from the next,
and they're full of surprises.
And Rome is always full of
surprises;
Rome a city,
of course, that you see layers
upon layer of civilization,
that one peels back to get us
back to antiquity,
but along the way experiences
some amazing things.
So I think that this particular
lecture,
which will talk about the
varied nature of Roman
architecture,
especially architecture
commissioned by individual
patrons to preserve their memory
for posterity,
again is particularly
appropriate.
I've called today's lecture
"Accessing Afterlife:
Tombs of Roman Aristocrats,
Freedmen, and Slaves."
We spoke on Tuesday about
public architecture commissioned
by the emperor Augustus,
public architecture that we
noted was made primarily out of
marble,
out of Luna or Carrara marble,
that was quarried on the
northwest coast of Italy itself,
and the objective of it being
to try to conjure up the
relationship between the new
Golden Age of Augustus and the
Golden Age,
fifth century B.C.,
of Periclean Athens.
Just as Julius Caesar had tried
to create a kind of Alexandria
on the Tiber,
we see Augustus trying to
recreate an Athens on the Tiber.
And Augustus was,
of course, very much--
in his objectives was very much
in keeping with other objectives
that we've been studying for
some time: this Hellenization of
Roman architecture that we have
addressed on a number of
occasions.
We spoke last time about the
Forum of Augustus in Rome,
featuring the Temple of Mars
Ultor,
that temple that Augustus vowed
he would build if he could be
victorious over the assassins of
Julius Caesar,
that is, Cassius and Brutus.
He was so, at the Battle of
Philippi, and he built this
forum and he built this temple
again as its centerpiece.
And you'll recall again that it
was made, for the most part,
out of Carrara marble.
We see the columns of Carrara
here, a wall,
the seventeen Carrara marble
steps, and so on.
We also talked about the Ara
Pacis Augustae,
the Altar of Augustan Peace,
put up to the diplomatic
agreements or treaties that
Augustus made with those in
Spain and Gaul:
a monument that was put up near
his earlier mausoleum,
a monument that was also made
out of Carrara marble,
and in fact solid Carrara
marble.
And this monument too had
precedents in the Greek period.
It looked back to a number of
sources,
but one of those,
as we noted on Tuesday,
was the Altar of the Twelve
Gods, or the Altar of Pity,
a fifth-century B.C.
monument that was located in
the marketplace of ancient
Greece.
So again, both of these
buildings, looking back to Greek
prototypes in their general
format,
and also, of course,
in the material out of which
they were made,
namely marble.
When we talked about the Ara
Pacis,
we talked about the fact that
it eventually ended up being
part of a kind of architectural
complex,
that while this architectural
complex may have not been
planned from the start,
it grew up over time into
something where all of the
buildings related to one another
in interesting ways,
both in terms of their content
and also in terms of their
architectural design.
The complex included the
Mausoleum of Augustus,
the tomb of the emperor
Augustus, which was the first
monument built on this site,
and eventually the Ara Pacis,
which you'll recall was
actually not located originally
where it is now.
It was located in an area a bit
here to the upper right
originally,
on the Via Flaminia that
Augustus took when he returned
to Rome from Spain and Gaul,
but that it was moved,
or the remains of it were moved
over to this location,
next to the Tiber,
by Mussolini,
because as we noted last time,
in the meantime a palace had
been built on top of the
original location of the Ara
Pacis,
and that area was no longer
available for use.
But again, the Mausoleum of
Augustus, the first building of
this complex.
You see in this aerial view
from Google Earth that the
mausoleum ended up becoming the
centerpiece of the Piazza
Augusto Imperatore,
that piazza that Mussolini's
architects designed to
commemorate Augustus and also to
commemorate Mussolini,
because that inscription I
showed you last time is inserted
into the building over here.
If we look at this aerial view
of the Mausoleum of Augustus,
which you'll see from your
Monument List was begun in 28
B.C.--
and in fact that should ring
some bells for you and we should
say something about its genesis
in 28 B.C.
Because you'll recall that
important date of 31;
31 the Battle of Actium when
Augustus was victorious over
Antony and Cleopatra and became
sole emperor,
or began his march to becoming
sole emperor of the Roman world.
It's interesting to see him
building this massive mausoleum
only three years after the
Battle of Actium;
that's really quite striking.
Why did he do that?
Well the reason that he seems
to have done that is despite the
fact that he lived until
76-years-old,
which was very old in ancient
Roman times,
as I mentioned last
time--despite the fact that he
lived to that ripe old age,
he was not in terribly good
health,
even as a young man,
and he was very concerned about
his own longevity.
How long was he going to live?
He knew he had accomplished a
lot already by this victory over
Antony and Cleopatra,
and by some of his other
military victories,
but he wasn't actually sure how
long he was going to last,
and so he begins to build this
gigantic tomb eventually to hold
his own remains.
And he completes that tomb in
five years.
It's built between 28 B.C.
and 23 B.C.
And you'll recall the date of
the Ara Pacis is considerably
later;
13 to 9 B.C.
So the Ara Pacis was only added
to this complex later,
and at that point the whole
thing was orchestrated with the
addition of the obelisk,
and we talked about how the
obelisk cast a shadow on the Ara
Pacis on Augustus' birthday,
and so on and so forth.
With regard to the tomb itself,
we're going to see something
quite striking today,
and that is that the tomb is
architecturally very different
from the Ara Pacis Augustae,
and indeed from the Forum of
Augustus.
And it's a good example of the
eccentricity,
as we'll characterize today,
of Roman tomb architecture in
general.
Keep in mind that Roman tomb
architecture is the most
personal of any form of Roman
architecture,
which makes it particularly
interesting to study,
because the only practical
requirement for a tomb was that
it be able to hold the remains
of the deceased.
That's all it needed to do,
whereas other buildings had to
do all kinds of other things:
have running water through
them, and so on and so forth.
But that was not the case here.
So that the patron and the
architect could come together to
create buildings that were
unique to that individual and
again were eccentric to a
certain degree,
and that is indeed what we will
see,
and that is the case also in
the Mausoleum of Augustus.
As we look down on the
Mausoleum of Augustus,
in this aerial view,
we see the general plan of it.
We see that there was a central
burial chamber;
that there was a hollow drum,
and around that hollow drum--
and all of this is made of
concrete construction--
around that hollow drum a
series of concentric rings,
a series of concentric rings,
as you can see them here,
again made out of concrete.
And then the outer wall--which
you can also see in this
view--the outer wall was faced
with travertine,
which is also interesting;
not Luna marble,
travertine blocks.
And let me show you another
somewhat closer view,
also from Google Earth,
to show you the structure.
So again the central burial
chamber;
the hollow drum;
the concentric rings around
that;
the travertine wall around that.
But, of course,
you're looking essentially at
the core.
This is not what the original
entire monument looked like.
And what it was,
was in fact there was an
earthen tumulus,
or an earthen mound,
that was placed on top of these
concentric rings,
and then at the very apex of
that earthen mound was a
gleaming bronze statue of the
emperor Augustus himself.
I think I can make this clearer
by showing you a plan of the
Mausoleum of Augustus.
And we see all the features
I've already described:
the central burial chamber,
the hollow drum,
again all made out of concrete
construction,
and the concentric rings around
that.
And then the cross-section at
the top is particularly helpful
I think because you can see the
way in which the concrete has
been built up by means obviously
of annular vaults,
the annular vaults that
ultimately support the gleaming
bronze statue of Augustus,
at the apex.
And you can also see in this
cross-section the earthen mound,
the way in which the earthen
mound is piled up on top of that
substructure,
that concrete substructure,
to create the dome-like shape
of the mausoleum on its own.
Now scholars who believe--and
we all believe in fact--that
again Augustus was a
philhellene, that he had a
particular penchant for things
Greek.
So you look at something like
this and you ask yourselves,
"Well, what's Greek about
this?
Why didn't he,
when he came to make the
decision about his last resting
place, why did he not want to be
laid to rest in the manner of
the Greeks?
Why doesn't this--why wasn't
this tomb made in the form,
for example,
of a Greek temple,
or something like that?
Why did he choose this
particular form?"
So scholars have debated for
quite some time whether there
are any tombs like this in
Greece,
or in Asia Minor--what kind of
tomb was Alexander the Great
buried in,
for example?
Well we don't know exactly for
sure, but that's one
possibility, that it might have
something to do with Alexander's
tomb.
Others--because Aeneas came
from burning Troy--
others have suggested
perhaps--and that's in Asia
Minor--
perhaps the way the Trojans
were buried might have something
to do with this selection.
But I think the model is much
closer at hand.
I think the model--myself,
I believe that the model comes
from Italy,
and that it's a very
interesting choice on the part
of Augustus,
because I think what it tells
us is that Augustus may have
wanted to build public buildings
in Rome that conjured up ancient
Athens,
but when it came to deciding
about how he wanted to be
buried,
he wanted to be buried in the
manner of his Italian ancestors.
Let me show you what I think is
a really important comparison.
We're looking on the left-hand
side of the screen once again at
the Mausoleum of Augustus,
as it looks today.
Here you see the central
entranceway.
You see what remains of the
concentric, concrete rings.
You see some of the travertine
facing for the outer ring of the
structure.
And you see,
of course, that the uppermost
part, namely the earthen mound,
is no longer there.
But if I compare the Mausoleum
of Augustus,
to what you see here on the
right-hand side of the screen,
which is an Etruscan tomb,
an Etruscan tomb from the
so-called--
and I put this on the Monument
List for you--
the Banditaccia Cemetery,
which is at a site called
Cerveteri,
Cerveteri, a very important
Etruscan site.
And this tomb we believe dates
to the sixth century B.C.
Cerveteri is an extraordinary
place to visit now because there
is one tomb after another of
this type.
You go into the site and you
feel like you're on another
planet or some such,
as you wander among these
extremely well-preserved tombs
at Cerveteri.
And Cerveteri,
by the way, is right off the
highway, between Rome and
Florence.
So it's a very easy site to get
to and very well worthwhile;
there's nothing quite like it
anywhere in Italy,
anywhere indeed in the world.
And you see these series--and
I've just chosen one here to
show you--
you see these series of tombs,
and I think if you look at it
you'll see the similarity of
this to the Mausoleum of
Augustus.
These round Etruscan tombs have
central burial chambers.
They have stone facing around
the outermost part of the
structure.
And you can see that piled on
top of that is an earthen mound,
and if you expand the size --
the Cerveteri tomb is much
smaller.
Actually the individual
Cerveteri tombs are smaller than
the Mausoleum of Augustus.
The Mausoleum of Augustus is
290 feet in diameter;
it's a very large building.
But if you expand the size of
one of these,
what we call tumulus,
t-u-m-u-l-u-s,
tumulus tombs,
at Cerveteri,
if you expand the size,
if you plant this with trees--
because we know that the
Mausoleum of Augustus was
planted with trees on the
earthen mound;
there's been quite a bit of
controversy about what kind of
trees.
For a long time people said
cypress trees.
Now people seem to favor
juniper trees.
But whatever,
trees of some sort,
decorating that earthen mound.
So if you enlarge this,
if you put some junipers on top
of it,
and if you stick a gleaming
bronze statue of Augustus at the
apex,
you will have essentially the
Mausoleum of Augustus.
So I'd like to suggest to you
today that the Mausoleum of
Augustus indicates to us that
when it came to his tomb,
Augustus wanted to be buried
like his Italian ancestors,
like the Etruscans,
and that is why he chose this
particular type of tomb in Rome.
The Mausoleum of Augustus,
like so many other monuments
that we've been looking at this
semester,
survives in large part because
it was re-used over the
centuries in a wide variety of
ways.
You can see in this engraving
that it was used at one point as
a garden,
a very nicely manicured garden,
as you can see inside the
remains,
inside those concentric
circles, a very nice garden.
It was also used as a fortress
at one point by the well-known
Colonna family of Italy.
It was used,
believe it or not,
as a bull ring--
a little touch of Spain in the
midst of Rome,
as a bull ring--and it was used
most recently as a music hall.
It was a music hall before it
was turned back into the
Mausoleum of Augustus.
So again, this very--a very
similar saga to this building
and to its post-antique history,
as to so many others that we've
talked about.
Another important point to make
about the Mausoleum of Augustus
is that,
although Augustus intended it
as his own last resting place,
he didn't intend for him to be
the only person who was laid to
rest there.
He wanted this to serve as a
family tomb,
for him, his wife,
his--well it turned out his
daughter didn't end up there,
but that may have been the
intention originally,
that she would.
She was discredited because of
all the adulterous affairs she
had and Augustus eventually
banished her in 2 B.C.
from Rome, razed her house to
the ground, and did not allow
her to be buried in the
Mausoleum of Augustus.
But for his wife,
for his nephew and son-in-law,
Marcellus, and others,
he wanted to create this family
tomb where he,
his family, and presumably,
since his objective was to
create a dynasty,
presumably where his successors
of the dynasty that he founded
would also be laid to rest.
And there are inscription
plaques that have come to light,
from the Mausoleum of Augustus,
and I can show you a couple of
them here,
that do indicate that was
exactly the case.
We see this plaque over here,
which actually has the name
Marcellus inscribed there.
This is the Marcellus of the
Theater of Marcellus,
the nephew and son-in-law of
Augustus, who was laid to rest
in this Mausoleum.
His sister, "soror,"
Octavia, also laid to rest;
that is, Augustus' sister,
Octavia, also laid to rest
here.
And it continued to be used as
a burial place again after
Augustus' death and through the
so-called Julio-Claudian
emperors,
who we'll look at next week:
Tiberius and Caligula and
Claudius.
And we see, in fact,
an inscription plaque over here
that honors Agrippina the Elder:
Agrippina the Elder,
the mother of Caligula,
the third emperor of Rome,
and it was Caligula who laid
his mother to rest in this tomb.
So very much a family tomb
created by the emperor Augustus.
And I should also mention,
with regard to burial practice
at this time,
that everybody was--imperial
individuals,
and those lower on the social
pyramid as well--
were all cremated at this
particular time.
So you have to imagine that
there were urns for each of
these inside the tomb somewhere
as well.
Now it may not surprise you to
hear that once the emperor chose
the form of his tomb,
that he set in motion a fashion
that just about every aristocrat
wanted to follow.
So all of a sudden,
after the construction of the
Mausoleum of Augustus,
again between 28 and 23,
there is this efflorescence of
round tombs in Rome and
elsewhere in Italy.
And I want to show you just one
example of that.
This is the so-called Tomb of
Caecilia Metella.
It dates to 20 B.C.
So it began to be put up not
too long after Augustus'
mausoleum was built.
It is located on the famous Via
Appia in Rome,
the Appian Way.
The Appian Way,
which you see--this is a Google
Earth image once again where you
can see a stretch of the Appian
Way,
or the Via Appia,
that is modern asphalt,
although there are remains--and
I'll show you later an example
of this--
there are remains of the
polygonal masonry pavement that
would have been there initially,
looking very much like the
pavement that we saw in Pompeii,
for example.
And you can see the Tomb of
Caecilia Metella right over
here.
Like the Mausoleum of Augustus,
it was re-used in ancient
times, and there was a fortress
and a palace that was added to
it.
And you can see also there,
in a reddish earth color,
the remains of that fortress
and palace that abutted the
mausoleum or the Tomb of
Caecilia Metella.
And while this is on the
screen, you can also see that
while the tomb was essentially a
cylindrical drum,
resembling the cylindrical drum
of the Mausoleum of Augustus,
it was placed--it was given
some height by being placed on a
podium--
the kind of podium that we saw
at the sanctuaries,
or the podium that we saw at
the Villa of the Mysteries--
to raise it up.
It's not as big as those,
but it's sizable,
and it raises this round tomb
up a little bit,
so that it can be more readily
seen as people make their way
along the Via Appia.
The Mausoleum of Augustus does
not have a similar podium.
So that's a unique,
a different feature that is
added to this particular
structure.
You can also see there's an
inscription on the front,
and we'll talk about that in a
moment, and then there are
crenellations at the top.
There's some dispute about when
those crenellations were added,
whether they belonged to the
original tomb or not.
I think it's highly unlikely
that they belonged to the
original tomb,
and they may have been added at
the time that this was made into
a fortress,
as I've already mentioned.
This is a view of the Tomb of
Caecilia Metella,
as it looks today,
this tomb of this woman of 20
B.C.,
and you can see that it's
actually quite well preserved,
and we can get a very good
sense of its original
appearance.
You can see the concrete podium
down here, without its original
facing;
it was surely faced.
You can see the great
cylindrical drum,
of the Tomb of Caecilia
Metella, and you can see the
facing.
And, once again,
the facing for this tomb,
just as in the Mausoleum of
Augustus, is not Luna or Carrara
marble.
It is travertine,
but very, very nicely cut
travertine blocks,
as you can see here.
Very well done.
She was undoubtedly a
well-to-do patron who was able
to hire the best architects,
the best artisans,
and they have done an
outstanding job of cutting that
travertine.
You can see also that there is
a frieze that encircles the
monument at the uppermost part,
right here, and that frieze
depicts garlands and skulls of
bulls,
bucrania;
the same sort of thing that we
saw in the inner precinct wall
of the Ara Pacis.
Although this pre-dates the Ara
Pacis, so we can't say it was
the influence of the Ara Pacis.
This is again 20,
whereas the Ara Pacis wasn't
begun until 13.
And it shows us that this motif
was very much in the air,
during the Augustan period,
this motif of garlands hanging
from bucrania,
which of course makes reference
to sacrifice,
and it could be a sacrifice in
honor of a funerary event,
as well as anything else,
and we again see that very well
here.
One very interesting fact is
that the frieze is not made out
of travertine but out of
pentelic marble,
p-e-n-t-e-l-i-c.
Pentelic marble is marble from
Mount Pentelikon in Greece.
So it tells us that marble was
imported from Greece,
or marble that was imported
from Greece was purchased and
used for the frieze of this
particular structure,
and we'll see that it was used
also for the inscription plaque.
So it tells us something.
It tells us that there
was--that some patrons made the
decision to spend a little more
for the material for what they
considered the most important
part of the monument.
So in this case the most
important part of the monument
was the frieze,
and also the inscription plaque
that preserved this woman's name
for posterity.
So they paid a little bit more
in order to get that more
expensive material for those
critical details of the
monument.
Here's the inscription.
We're very fortunate that it's
still preserved today.
We see it still inserted into
the monument.
Again, it's done in pentelic
marble, and I think you can see,
even in this view,
the difference between pentelic
marble and travertine.
Travertine has more texture to
it than the plainer marble,
as you can see.
And her name is given here,
Caecilia Metella:
Caecilia Metella down here.
And it tells us that she was
the daughter F(filia),
f-i-l-i-a, the daughter of
Quintus Q.
Creticus--Creticus,
C-r-e-t-i-c-u-s--who may have
come from Crete;
it's possible.
And it also makes reference to
the fact that she was married to
someone by the name of Crassus.
This may be Crassus the Elder;
we're not absolutely sure.
But what it does indicate to us
is this is an aristocratic
woman.
This is an aristocratic woman
whose family has a great deal of
money, who are honoring her with
this tomb, in the mode of the
day;
which of course was the tomb
type that was chosen by Augustus
himself.
You may have noticed up here,
in this same detail,
not only the frieze that we've
already described,
with the garlands and
bucrania,
but that there is a relief here
that represents a Roman trophy.
What is a Roman trophy?
What the Romans did at the end
of battle,
if they were victorious,
is they went over to the
nearest tree trunk on the
battlefield and they took arms
and armor from their defeated
enemy and they tacked that arms
and armor up on that tree trunk,
to create a military trophy
commemorating their victory,
right on the battlefield.
And that's exactly what you see
here, a tree trunk with a
breastplate and a helmet and
shields and so on,
all tacked up to that trophy.
So we have to ask ourselves,
what is that trophy doing on
this particular monument?
It's highly unlikely that it
refers to--there are some
instances;
we do hear about woman trying
to raise money for troops and so
on and so forth.
But we don't--and even thinking
that they might go into battle
-- but for the most part Roman
women did not participate in
battle.
So it is highly unlikely that
this refers to a military
encounter that she had.
More likely it either refers to
a military encounter of her
father or her husband,
or it may be a more generic
reference to victory.
We've talked about the fact
that in the minds of the Romans,
the victory in battle,
victory in the hunt,
often were conflated with
victory over death.
So it could be a more generic
reference,
but I would guess it may have
something to do more
specifically with the conquest
of her husband or her father.
The structure today is just
right there, out on the Via
Appia;
easy to see.
There is a small museum that
isn't all that often open,
but sometimes it is,
that is in the remains of the
fortress, and the palace next
door.
You can see that the outside of
the monument,
they've inserted a lot of finds
just from--
it doesn't mean they came from
the Tomb of Caecilia Metella --
but from this area on the Via
Appia.
There were tons of Roman tombs
out here,
and all of this paraphernalia
that you see,
statuary and fragments of
friezes and cornices and so on,
all come in part possibly from
this monument,
but more likely from the other
tombs in the area.
Those have been inserted into
the wall in a kind of
interesting way.
And then here's the museum
itself.
The museum doesn't have--the
stuff that's in there is pretty
much the same sort of thing that
you see here.
But going into the museum is
interesting because you can see
into the central chamber of the
Tomb of Caecilia Metella and see
the concrete construction and so
on.
I mentioned already that Roman
tombs could be very eccentric
indeed,
and I want to show you one of
the two most eccentric tombs,
in my opinion,
from ancient Rome that one can
see in the city of Rome today.
And the first of these is the
so-called Tomb of Cestius,
because we believe--in fact,
we're absolutely sure--
that it honors a man by the
name of Gaius,
G-a-i-u-s Cestius,
C-e-s-t-i-u-s;
Gaius Cestius.
It was put up in 15 B.C.
That is in the age of the
emperor Augustus.
In this Google Earth aerial
view, we see what that structure
looks like today.
It is a Roman tomb in the form
of an Egyptian pyramid.
It's the only Roman tomb in the
form of an Egyptian pyramid that
we can see in Rome today,
but we know there were others
in antiquity.
We have reports that tell us
that certain others that existed
at a certain time were torn
down, at one point.
There was one,
for example,
not far from the Vatican,
that was torn down at one
point, because it got in the way
of the street.
So this is not unique in the
sense of the only one,
although it is the only one
still surviving today.
We have no idea how many of
these there were.
There were certainly some.
Whether there were a lot,
we can't be absolutely certain.
But here it is,
a Roman tomb,
in the form of a pyramid.
Now when it was first put up,
it was put up outside the
Servian Walls of the city,
because all--as we've talked
about the fact that by Roman law
the necropolis or city of the
dead needed to be located
outside the walls of the city.
But as the city grew,
and as there was a need for a
new wall--
and this happened in the third
century A.D.,
and we'll talk about it way at
the end of this semester--
the Romans ended up building a
new wall,
the famous Aurelian Walls.
And the circuit happened to be
planned for this particular--to
pass this particular point where
the Tomb of Cestius was.
And fortunately they recognized
the aesthetic and historical
value of this tomb,
and decided not to tear it
down, but rather to incorporate
it into the Aurelian Walls.
So what you see in this aerial
view are two of the walls--
two parts of the Aurelian Walls
abutting,
and in fact incorporating,
the Pyramid of Cestius,
but in antiquity--when it was
first built,
excuse me, it stood alone.
And what you see over here is a
gateway that also belongs to the
later Aurelian Walls.
So again, fortunately this
particular tomb was preserved.
These two engravings are
helpful in showing us that the
inner core of the Tomb of
Cestius was concrete,
and the outer pyramidal shape
was faced once again with
travertine.
So travertine clearly the
material of choice by
aristocrats--
because we're going to see that
Cestius was also an aristocrat--
for their tombs in the age of
Augustus: concrete core,
travertine facing.
And then if you look at this
cutaway view over here,
you will see that the burial
chamber inside was very,
very, very small;
very, very, very small.
So small enough that there was
not a lot of space for these
burials;
but we'll see that we still
believe that this too was a
family tomb.
The burial chamber has had,
and still has,
remnants of painted walls.
And I show you an engraving
here of those walls that was
made when they were in somewhat
better shape than they are
today.
And I wondered if any of
you--you're such experts now on
First to Fourth Style Roman wall
painting--
if any of you could tell
me--I'm sure all of you could
tell me--
what style painting is being
used in the burial chamber of
the Tomb of Cestius?
Student:  Third Style.
Prof: Third style.
Why Third Style?
Student:  There's
floating mythological features
and very thin columns.
Prof: Very thin
candelabra here,
and mythological figures.
How are those used that
make--that show that this is a
typical Third Style wall?
Student:  They have a
blackout laying around them and
they're just floating around in
space.
Prof: That's the word,
floating.
They are floating in this
random space,
right in the center of the
panels, as we know was
characteristic of Third Style
Roman wall painting.
So 15 B.C., Third Style Roman
wall painting.
And if you think back to some
of the palaces or villas that we
looked at and their dates--think
of Boscotrecase for example,
11 B.C.
You see this is roughly
contemporary to what's happening
in Campania at this particular
time.
And here are two details of the
remains of those paintings,
and you can see one of these
floating mythological figures
that looks like a victory
figure: female,
winged, carrying a wreath over
here,
flying in the center of the
panel.
This also shows you,
in this case,
the panels were white,
very similar to the walls,
for example,
of the Third Style in the Domus
Aurea in Rome.
And then here,
this candelabrum,
very attenuated,
very delicate,
that is used in place of
columns;
both of these motifs decorating
the flat wall that was so
characteristic of Third Style
Roman wall painting.
Here's another view of the
pyramid as it looks today.
You can see it is exceedingly
well preserved,
one of the best preserved of
all Roman tombs.
You can see again the way in
which the later wall was built
into it,
and you can also see the
travertine blocks and how
carefully carved they were by
the designers,
by the artisans.
And here, this is very helpful,
because it shows you that the--
at least one,
but I can tell you that two
sides of the tomb,
the eastern and western sides
of the tomb,
had in the center of the
pyramid the name of Cestius.
That's how we know it was his
tomb.
You see it here, Gaius Cestius.
And it also includes all of his
titles.
So he was very happy to
advertise his titles on this
monument,
the purpose of which,
of course, was for those who
mourned him to feel proud of him
and his achievements.
But even more important than
that, from his point of view I
am sure,
and from the point of view of
the Romans in general,
was that his name and his deeds
be preserved for posterity so
that someday--
in 2009, we're sitting in this
classroom looking at this--
we think back on Cestius,
his title,
what he did,
what he achieved,
and the way in which he was
memorialized.
So this whole idea of
preserving memory,
not only in your own time,
but into the far flung future.
This tomb, as I said,
despite the fact that the
burial chamber is small,
we do believe it was a family
tomb.
We have evidence for that,
because two bases were found
that seemed to belong to this
tomb;
in fact, it's Cestius' name,
or members of his family,
Cestius, you can see there,
are named in these
inscriptions.
These have markings on the top
that suggest to us that statues
stood on them,
at one point.
So these were statue bases,
probably placed right in front
of the entrance to the pyramidal
tomb.
And if you cast your eyes over
this inscription you will not
only see the name Cestius a few
times,
but you will see another very
important name,
and that is M.***Agrippa.
That's Marcus Agrippa,
that's the Marcus Agrippa,
the longtime--the boyhood
friend and longtime close
confidant and onetime heir and
son-in-law of Augustus;
all of those things.
He's mentioned here.
So he is a member also of this
family.
So it demonstrates to us again
we are dealing with an
aristocratic family.
So all of those tombs I've
shown you thus far--
the Mausoleum of Augustus,
the Tomb of Caecilia Metella,
and the Tomb of Gaius
Cestius--are all examples of
aristocratic tomb architecture
in the age of Augustus.
Why did he choose a pyramid for
his tomb is a very interesting
question to ask,
and I would suggest here--and
it's not rocket science to
figure this out at all--
I would suggest here though
that the reason has to do with
Augustus' very important victory
over Mark Antony and Cleopatra
at the Battle of Actium in 31.
It was at that time,
and even before,
that an interest in things
Egyptian came into Rome.
We saw that Augustus himself
made reference to his victory
over that pair,
over Cleopatra and Mark Antony,
in the complex with the Ara
Pacis and the Mausoleum of
Augustus,
by inserting that obelisk in
the center;
an obelisk that I have
mentioned to you was actually
brought from Egypt itself.
So these references to Egypt,
initially under Augustus
himself, had political import.
It was there to show that
Augustus had been--
that obelisk was there to show
that Augustus had prevailed over
Mark Antony and Cleopatra,
and because he had prevailed,
he could steal obelisks from
Egypt and bring them back to
decorate Rome,
as trophies essentially.
So that was a political
statement on his part.
But as time went on,
Egyptomania became a kind of
fashion statement.
I think that it caught on;
it caught on after Egypt was
made a Roman province in 30
B.C.,
right after Actium,
and we begin to see this wave
of things Egyptian spreading
through Rome,
and it's likely that
Cestius--perhaps a combination
of both,
since he's from Agrippa's
family, this combination of
political reference,
but also just this was an
interesting--
this was the style at this
particular point,
to do things in the Egyptian
manner.
You might remember some of
those Egyptianizing motifs that
we saw,
for example,
from the Black Room at
Boscotrecase,
which was also a villa that was
closely connected with the
imperial family.
You remember Agrippa Postumus
who was the son of Agrippa
himself, born by his wife Julia,
after Agrippa's death;
hence his name.
Another view of the back of the
Pyramid of Cestius,
the Mausoleum of Cestius,
which again shows us how well
preserved it is.
You can see the Aurelian Walls,
you can see the gate that we
looked at before,
and you can also see that the
back is actually in a modern
cemetery.
This is the so-called
Protestant Cemetery,
and if you are in Rome and have
time, this is one of the most
interesting places to visit.
It's again a bit off the beaten
track.
Not that many tourists go
there, but those that do are
rewarded,
because it's a cemetery where
many expatriates were buried --
people who flocked to Rome
because they loved it.
Authors, scholars,
poets, painters came to Rome,
ended up spending the rest of
their lives there--
coming from all different
countries around the world--
spending the rest of their
lives there,
dying there,
and eventually being buried in
the so-called Protestant
Cemetery.
Percy Bysshe Shelley,
for example,
is buried there,
as is John Keats.
And the Keats tomb,
Keats marker,
is my favorite by far in this
cemetery.
You can see his tombstone here,
which doesn't even give his
name, it just identifies him;
and you'll remember he died
very, very young,
in his early twenties I think
it was.
You see him here referred to
only as "the young English
poet."
And down below it says,
"Here lies one whose name
was writ in water."
It's an amazing stone.
It does show the lyre,
which makes reference,
of course, to the fluency and
so on of his mellifluous poetry.
And over here,
a companion of his,
Joseph Severn,
who doesn't hesitate to mention
his relationship to John Keats.
So you see Keats' name in
Severn's tombstone but not in
Keats' own tombstone.
But I show this to you just
because it's one of those more
fascinating places in Rome.
And many of the tombs,
by the way--there are many
tombstones here that clearly are
based on ancient Roman
prototypes.
So it's a fascinating place to
wander.
And by the way,
you can do that in our own
Grove Street Cemetery,
where there are a number of
tombs that are done very much in
the Roman style.
If you think the Tomb of
Cestius is unusual,
the weirdest tomb by far in
Rome, from ancient Rome,
is the one that I turn to now,
and this is the Tomb of the
baker Eurysaces,
the Tomb of the baker Eurysaces
that was put up in Rome in the
late first century B.C.
And that again is another tomb
from the age of Augustus.
But in this case we believe,
although the inscription
doesn't tell us this for sure,
but we believe it is highly
likely that Eurysaces is from a
different level of Roman
society,
not an aristocrat,
but a working man who
probably--
either he himself or his family
were slaves originally,
eventually freed.
He takes up the profession of
bread making and he ends up
building this extraordinary tomb
that I'm going to show you in
some detail, in Rome.
As we look at this particular
view, we see the Tomb of
Eurysaces, as it looks today;
it's right over here.
We see it has behind it a great
travertine gate,
which is actually later in
date.
It dates to the time of the
emperor Claudius.
We'll talk about it next week.
So you have to think that away
for the moment.
That was not standing when the
Tomb of Eurysaces was put up.
You can also see,
however, that this gate was
placed in an aqueduct system.
That aqueduct was begun during
the time of Augustus.
So you can imagine that at
least some of that aqueduct
system stood at the time that
this tomb was built.
The tomb, as you can see here,
was a three-storied structure,
very eccentric in its
appearance.
The ground line today is much
lower than the modern ground
line.
So you have to go right up to
the monument.
You can look down at the first
story.
So you're only seeing a part of
the first story here.
You can see that it is made of
tufa blocks.
You can also see the interior
is concrete,
the core of the structure is
concrete,
and then on the second and
third stories,
the tomb is faced with
travertine.
So travertine again used for
tomb facing in the age in
Augustus.
And we see this very unusual
design where there are these
great--not piers--cylinders,
great cylinders;
great cylinders that are placed
here vertically,
and then cylinders placed in
the next tier horizontally.
Vertically placed cylinders.
They're not columns.
You don't see any capitals.
They're very fat.
So they are cylinders,
vertically, and then
horizontally.
And some scholars have
suggested, and I think quite
convincingly,
that these may actually make
reference to what were grain
measures.
Grain measures were these
cylindrical structures in silos,
in a sense, in which they
stored grain in ancient Roman
times.
So that is very possible,
since we know that this man was
a baker,
that this may make reference to
these grain storage cylinders
that were used in the process of
baking.
With regard to the siting of
the tomb--
this is particularly
interesting--I show you this
plan over here,
which indicates to us--here you
can actually see the plan of the
Tomb of Eurysaces,
and you can see that it is very
unusual in shape.
It is trapezoidal in shape.
Why is it trapezoidal in shape?
It probably is trapezoidal in
shape because the tomb was
located on a piece of property
that was between two major roads
of Rome that exited and entered
the city at this particular
point: the so-called Via
Labicana and the Via
Praenestina.
So two major Roman roads that
come into the city at this
point.
And remember,
the Tomb of Eurysaces,
like all Roman tombs during
this period,
was outside the Servian Walls,
so built outside the walls,
but between these two streets.
Now this model over here,
which by the way comes from a
museum in Rome that again is off
the beaten track,
but I can highly recommend the
Museo Civilit
Romana,
which is in a building built by
Mussolini in the 1930s for a
World's Fair,
and the buildings--and it and
other buildings like it out
there,
in a place--part of Rome that
we call EUR from Esposizione
Universale di Roma,
E-U-R, EUR.
That whole area built up by
Mussolini for the World's Fair.
But the buildings were so
substantial that they decided to
keep them, and they still stand,
and this museum was placed in
one of them.
It is a museum of casts,
where you can go and see works
of Roman art and architecture
from not only Rome but from
around the world,
all in one place.
Now they're not originals,
they're casts,
but it'd be a great place to
study for the exam for this
course,
for example,
because you can walk around and
see so many of the buildings
that we've talked about.
And there are these wonderful
models of many of them.
And we see here a model of this
aqueduct, the later gate here,
and the Tomb of Eurysaces.
And this shows you very well
the way in which these two
streets,
the Labicana and the
Praenestina, came into Rome at
this point,
converged exactly on the
faade of this tomb.
And this--it is clear that
Eurysaces--
and I'll tell you how he did
this in a moment--
had enough money that he was
able to buy what was certainly
one of the most choice pieces of
real estate,
outside the walls of Rome,
one in which everyone who came
into Rome from either of those
two thoroughfares would see the
faade of this tomb.
This is a man who wanted to be
remembered for posterity.
It's another example of how
tombs were used for the purposes
of retaining memory over time.
This is also interesting
because it shows what happened.
What you see with the dotted
lines here is one of these later
gates that was made for the
Aurelian Walls.
And in this case,
the Tomb of Eurysaces was right
smack dab in the middle of where
they wanted to build an
outcropping of this wall.
In this case they decided that
they were not going to build the
wall into it,
but that they were going to
build the wall on top of it.
But fortunately,
again, they did not destroy it
completely.
They did shear off the front of
the tomb,
which actually took away the
faade,
but they allowed the debris to
fall into the tower,
and then they covered it up.
So when this tower was
eventually torn down to free the
Tomb of Eurysaces,
they found the fourth wall and
the debris from that wall,
including a portrait statue and
an inscription inside the
debris,
which was extremely fortunate,
and which allows us to
reconstruct the monument.
Here you see the model in this
EUR Museum that shows you what
the tomb looked like in
antiquity.
You see the three levels,
the three tiers.
You see the entrance to the
burial chamber here.
And this is the faade
that we're looking at;
this is the part that no longer
survives.
This is the fourth wall or the
faade,
now gone, but we can again
reconstruct it from those
remains.
And you see them here,
and you see it was relatively
plain on three tiers,
except for a portrait statue of
Eurysaces and his wife,
an inscription down below.
And you need to think away the
frieze up there,
because the frieze was probably
not on this side of the
monument,
although there was a frieze
around the other three sides.
You can see one of those sides
here, and I'll show that frieze
to you momentarily.
This is a view of the tomb
again, where we can see so well
those cylinders on two stories.
And you can also see here that
in the area between the vertical
and the horizontal cylinders,
on three sides of the monument,
there is an inscription,
and it repeats over and over
again,
and it tells us that this
monument was put up by
Eurysaces,
Marcus Vergilius Eurysaces,
who was pistor and
redemptor--
p-i-s-t-o-r,
r-e-d-e-m-p-t-o-
r--pistor and
redemptor.
That means master baker and
contractor--the contractor is
the most important part--master
baker and contractor.
We know this is a man who made
bread and sold it to the Roman
armies.
This was a pretty lucrative
thing to do in the age of
Augustus when there was so much
military conquest.
He made a fortune selling bread
to the Roman armies,
and it is with that fortune
that he was able to buy this
choice piece of real estate and
to put up this extraordinary
monument in the late first
century B.C.
The portrait relief still
survives.
It's in the Capitoline Museums
today.
You see it here.
It had fallen in again to the
debris,
from the fourth side,
but here it is with Eurysaces
standing next to his wife,
Atistia--we know her name and
I'll tell you how in a moment--
Atistia, in that portrait
relief.
And we're not going to go into
this in any detail,
but if you compare it to the
figures of Augustus and his
family,
from the Ara Pacis,
I think you'll agree with me
that the Ara Pacis is serving as
a model,
and that this portrait group is
clearly based on aristocratic--
even though this is probably a
middle-class pair,
formerly from a slave family,
freed people.
They are shown here very much
as if they are members of the
court, wearing similar costumes,
depicted in a similar way,
with similar hairstyles.
And I point to just one detail.
If you look at this view of
Livia, on the Ara Pacis,
Augustus' wife,
and you see the wonderful way
in which the artist has depicted
her hand,
the shape of her hand showing
underneath her garment here;
the same is done here for
Atistia, you can see--and that's
A-t-i-s-t-i-a--for Atistia.
You can see her hand.
In fact, it's even better done
here because you can see the
shape of the knuckles and so on,
underneath the garment,
the very diaphanous garment
that she wears.
So clearly a very special
portrait artist,
probably hired to do these
portraits;
a portrait artist who may have
been hired at great expense.
And also very significant,
and in keeping with what we saw
for the Tomb of Caecilia
Metella,
is the fact that although the
tomb is faced in travertine and
the relief around the monument
is in travertine,
this is done in marble,
in, if I remember correctly,
Greek marble, as well.
So imported marble that is
brought from elsewhere and at
greater expense is used for the
most important portrait relief.
The scenes around the--the
scenes,
the frieze scenes,
are particularly interesting
because they depict in the
greatest of detail the
profession of the making of
bread.
They depict Eurysaces' daily
achievement of making bread that
he sold to the Roman armies.
I'm going to just show you the
scenes very quickly,
and you can see the style is
very different.
It's a much more journalistic
style,
with figures that don't have
the elegant proportions that we
saw in the portrait relief,
and it is carved on travertine,
not on marble.
We see here the grain being
ground between two stones,
and we see the way in which
these men in tunics worked that.
We also see that the upper
stone is rotated by a mule that
is attached to a wooden handle
that comes off the uppermost
stone there.
We have millstones just like
this, from Pompeii,
and I show you the actual
millstones.
So these depictions on the Tomb
of Eurysaces:
very accurate in terms or what
millstones looked like in
antiquity.
Another scene here in which we
see two men at a table with big
gobs of dough,
that you can see here,
dough, for the bread.
Another scene--this is one of
the more important scenes--where
we see four men standing behind
a table, that are forming that
dough into loaves.
And over here a magistrate,
who has a short-sleeved but
long garment,
is supervising them.
And the four men are very
interestingly rendered because
they're rendered almost exactly
the same.
If you look,
if you compare this to the Ara
Pacis where figures are
represented in different
postures,
a lot of variety,
clearly based on Greek
prototypes.
Here we see something very
different.
The major objective of the
artist is to get the story
across, to show these men making
these loaves.
But look at them.
Each one--they're bare chested,
and we'll see why they're bare
chested.
It's hot in this part of the
bakery.
So they've taken off their
shirts.
There's some attempt to depict
their musculature.
But they're essentially shown
in exactly the same way,
the same curly hair,
almost as if they were cut from
a cookie cutter,
because again it's not the form
that's of interest to the artist
here,
but getting that narrative
across.
And if you try to figure out
whose legs belong to whom,
believe me, you'll have a
difficult time of it.
So the artist is not--is much
less concerned with formal
things than he is with getting
the story across.
With regard to why they've
taken off their shirts,
they're right near the oven.
And I show you the scene that
depicts the dome-shaped oven in
which the loaves are being
baked,
and you can see that this oven
looks very much like a modern
pizza oven,
and in fact the pole that they
use,
the wooden pole with the flat
end, is just the sort of thing
you see at BAR or any other
major pizza place,
either in New Haven or
elsewhere in the world.
And, in fact,
these dome-shaped ovens are
still used in rural areas.
And I took this view in Greece,
in a small rural town,
and you see these in Italy in
some very small towns as well,
still being done in exactly the
same way.
There are a number--because of
the cylinders on the Tomb of
Eurysaces,
there are some scholars who've
suggested that the Tomb of
Eurysaces is in the form of a
bakery .
While I do believe that there
is reference to those grain--
to those storage bins,
silos that were used for the
storage of grain,
I do not think that the Tomb of
Eurysaces is in the form of an
oven.
It makes reference to baking,
but I don't think it's in the
form of an oven,
because this is what Roman
ovens looked like.
They were dome-shaped.
This has a very different
appearance, as you can see.
Perhaps the most important
scene in the frieze is this one,
where we see two--we see the
loaves have been baked,
they're ready to go to market,
and they're put in these large
baskets--
you can see them here--and then
they are weighed in this scale,
in this ancient scale.
And I think this is a form of
private propaganda on the part
of the baker Eurysaces.
What he is telling the public
who gaze up on this tomb,
not only in his own day but for
posterity,
is: "My bread was always,
not only of high quality,
but of the appropriate weight.
I never cheated the public.
I treated you fairly.
I was an honest baker and
contractor."
I think that's what the message
is here.
And, in fact,
you may think this is a
stretch,
but I think that one could
easily compare this report that
Eurysaces provides of his
profession on the frieze of this
tomb as a kind of baker's
version of Augustus' Res
Gestae.
The list of things accomplished
during his life is laid out in
narrative form,
for not only his contemporaries
but for posterity to see.
The portrait group again--and I
mentioned that there was an
inscription found with that
portrait group;
a very interesting inscription
which tells us that Eurysaces
put up this monument to his wife
Atistia,
and Atistia's bodily remains,
he says,
are buried in hoc
panario--in hoc
panario,
in this panarium.
What is a panarium?
A breadbasket;
which is again why scholars
have said, "Well the whole
tomb is in the form of an
oven."
But I think the breadbasket
being referred to here is not
the tomb, but rather the urn in
which Atistia's remains were
placed.
In the excavation in the
nineteenth century,
when that later gateway was
removed,
they found one urn,
one urn, not two urns,
one urn, presumably the urn of
Atistia,
and that urn was in the
form--it was drawn at that time.
And we can see this view of it
here, a cross-section,
the lid, and the main body of
the urn.
And you can see it looks like a
breadbasket.
And I show you--we have lots of
examples of urns in the form of
breadbaskets from Roman times.
There's one in the Metropolitan
Museum of Art,
and any of you who are going
down there anytime soon to look
at Roman antiquities and other
things,
you can see one there.
This one is in the National
Museum in Rome.
And women's remains were often
placed in breadbaskets to
accentuate or to speak to their
domestic virtues,
if they were good at taking
care of the house and baking
bread and so on.
But in this particular case I
think it is much more likely
that the reference here is not
to her,
to Atistia's cleverness as a
housekeeper,
but rather to her husband's
profession,
which is very,
very interesting in terms of
what it tells us about the
gender wars of antiquity,
that here's a tomb that has
been put up by this baker,
with his money that he's made
from his profession,
in honor of his wife.
But what he depicts -- what he
is preserving for posterity is
not the outline of his wife's
life,
but the outline of his life,
what he has accomplished.
His name is plastered on three
sides of the monument.
He's got three sides of the
monument with the successive
phases of the baking of bread in
all of its aspects.
Yes, he has a very nice
portrait relief of his wife,
but of course he's standing by
her side.
And he does mention her name
down below.
So he gives her some due.
But this monument,
as far as posterity is
concerned,
is about Eurysaces and not
about his wife,
and I think it tells us again
very--
a great deal about the motives
of this particular individual.
I want to say just a very few
words about two other tombs out
on the Via Appia in Rome,
the Appian Way again.
And I show you a view of the
Via Appia, as it looks today.
You can see that although much
of the road is modern,
you do find bits and pieces of
ancient ground out there.
You can see some polygonal
blocks here and some rut marks
from the ancient road,
and you have to be very careful
when you drive out there in your
Cinquecento,
or whatever--or you bike ride
out there,
as this fellow is doing,
or you take your motorbike or
whatever--
because if you're going too
quickly and you don't expect it,
all of a sudden you hit some
ancient road,
and that makes a huge
difference in terms of your
ability to move forward.
I want to show you one tomb,
very fleetingly,
out there, which is the one
that you see over here on the
left-hand side of the screen.
There are remains of many tombs
on the Via Appia.
Most of them are just piles of
concrete, but a few of them are
better preserved,
and this is one of them.
It's a tomb of freedmen and
freedwomen from 13 B.C.
to A.D. 5.
We call it the Rabirius Tomb
because of an inscription that
tells us members of the Rabirius
family were buried here.
The reason that I show it to
you is that the eccentric tombs
that I've shown you today are
absolutely marvelous and tell us
a lot about the Romans as
patrons and their desires
vis--vis memory.
But it is not--those are not
the conventional tomb types.
We see many more of this sort
of thing, which we call a house
tomb, a tomb that resembles a
house essentially.
It has a sloping ceiling and a
main faade,
and in that faade there
is usually a portrait relief,
either vertical or horizontal,
but these horizontal ones
represent members of the family.
Some may be deceased,
some may not be deceased.
The message is that even if
someone has died before another,
that they will eventually be
re-united together in
perpetuity.
But if you look at this
carefully,
you will see that what it looks
like is as if these individuals
are still alive and looking out
of the window of their tomb,
as if out of the window of a
house;
this very close association in
the minds of the Romans between
houses of the living and houses
of the dead.
And that is absolutely the case
here.
And you'll remember,
we can trace this all the way
back to the eighth century B.C.
You remember the Villanovan hut
urn that I showed you,
and I told you that women's
remains were placed in--
women's cremated remains--were
placed in these huts that
resembled Romulus' huts.
And so this whole idea of a
house serving as a tomb goes way
back,
and continues to be a leitmotif
of Roman tomb architecture
throughout the entire history of
Roman architecture,
and it's something that I hope
you'll keep in mind.
Also just in passing,
I want to mention--
we've looked--the tombs that
we've looked at thus far today
have been--
they've been of all different
social classes,
from emperor to freed slave,
but at the same time they have
all been tombs,
including the Rabirius Tomb,
of the well-to-do.
If these were freed slaves,
they were ones that made a
fortune,
like Eurysaces did selling
bread to the Roman army,
and with that fortune were able
to build monumental tombs,
at great expense.
But there were lots and lots of
people obviously,
who lived in Rome and Pompeii
and in other cities who could
not afford those kinds of tombs,
and you might be asking
yourselves,
"Where are all of those
people buried?"
Well they tended to be buried
underground,
in what we call
columbaria --
c-o-l-u-m-b-a-r-i-a,
columbaria--underground
burial chambers,
that were either burial clubs
that you could join for a small
amount of money;
you could join one of these
clubs, buy into your last
resting place that way.
Or they were burial chambers
that were created by the very
well to do, for example,
the emperor and empress,
Augustus and Livia.
We know they had thousands of
slaves, literally thousands of
slaves.
We have a record of some of
Livia's slaves.
She had slaves,
not only to tend the garden and
that kind of thing,
but she had a masseuse,
she had several hairstylists,
and she even had a slave,
we know, who set her pearls,
that was her whole job was to
set her pearls,
day in and day out.
So they had tons and tons of
slaves,
and some of those very well to
do also established these burial
areas where their slaves could
find a last resting place.
And, in fact,
the one that I show you here,
the Vigna Codini,
is one such,
that belonged to the
Augustan-Julio-Claudian family
and was used for the remains of
some of their slaves.
And you can see that each
individual had a little niche;
again, people were cremated.
The cremated remains were
placed usually in an urn,
that was placed inside one of
these niches,
and then there would be a small
inscription,
referring to the deceased.
So this gives you a sense again
of those who could not afford
individual tombs and how they
were buried.
In the five or seven minutes
that remain,
I'd like to switch gears
entirely and look at something
very different,
as a prelude to what we'll be
talking about next time,
because next time,
next Tuesday,
we are going to return once
again to innovative Roman
architecture;
architecture made of concrete
and with a variety of
interesting innovations.
We'll do that next week,
as I said.
And I want to give you an
introduction to that by turning
to this one example from the
Augustan period that is
noteworthy enough for us to say
something about it.
What you're looking at here is
the plan of what was a spa
essentially, in ancient Roman
times.
It's located in Campania,
at a place called Baia,
so in the vicinity of Pompeii
and Herculaneum and Oplontis and
Boscotrecase and so on.
We've already talked about the
fact that that was an area that
was a mecca for the well-to-do,
the glitteratti from Rome who
went down there for their
vacations.
It was a resort area.
Many of them had villas along
what is now the Amalfi Coast.
Others had villas on the Island
of Capri.
I can't remember if I told you
but Augustus and Tiberius,
his successor,
owned twelve villas on the
Island of Capri,
one of which we'll look at next
time.
And this was an area also where
there were sulfur springs and
mineral baths,
and so the natural thing to do,
for those who were coming here,
as a resort,
was to create for them a place
that they could go to relax and
enjoy the thermal springs and
the sulfur baths and so on and
so fort,
and that was this place,
this spa, at Baia,
which consisted of a bunch of
thermal structures that were
terraced out over a hillside.
You have to think of the
Sanctuary of Fortuna Primigenia
at Palestrina,
turned into a spa.
Because they treated
it--architecturally it was done
in exactly the same way.
They took a hillside,
they terraced that hillside,
they poured concrete on that
hillside,
creating a whole host of
interesting structures in which
one could relax and get away
from it all.
You see a plan of that spa here
and the way in which it was
terraced, via concrete
construction,
over this hillside.
I am only going to show you one
thermal bath from it,
and it's this one that we see
over here.
It is the so-called
"Temple of Mercury"
-- that's what the locals have
long called it.
It is not a Temple of Mercury,
it is a thermal bath,
but nonetheless we call it that
because it's been called that
for such a long time.
As you look at the plan of the
Temple of Mercury,
you're going to say to
me--every one of you will say
the same thing,
"What's the origin of
this?"
Clearly the design is based on
the frigidaria of
Pompeii,
the frigidarium or the
cold room of Pompeii,
this round structure with the
radiating alcoves that we saw as
part of bath architecture very
early on,
second century B.C.,
and so on, in Pompeii.
Same scheme used here.
Not surprising.
This is in Campania,
it's not far away.
I can show you the Temple of
Mercury is extremely well
preserved.
We can see the dome of the
Temple of Mercury,
made out of concrete
construction,
from above.
You can see the oculus
of the--
just as those frigidaria
had oculi,
this one does as well,
and you can see that extremely
well here.
So a concrete building,
with a concrete dome,
used as part of this spa.
We've traced this desire to
make round structures way back
to the 600s B.C.,
the time of Quinto Fiorentino.
I showed you this Etruscan
attempt at making a round
structure,
with a dome,
that was done,
in this case,
in stone, and although it was a
valiant attempt,
not all that successful.
And we talked about the way in
which that eventually
transformed into the Roman
ability to make the
frigidaria at Pompeii.
And here are two views of the
Temple of Mercury at Baia,
as it looks today.
Because of the oculus,
there is often rain water.
The drain no longer functions.
So there's often a lot of very
unappealing green water that
accumulates in the base of the
Temple of Mercury.
So the times that I've been
there, every time I think I've
been there,
there's been enough water in
there that I haven't been able
to actually get pictures of the
alcoves,
which are covered by these
inches and inches of water that
are usually collected inside the
Temple of Mercury.
But you get a good sense,
I think,
of it here nonetheless,
that we're talking about a
round domed structure,
with an oculus,
with some windows,
with arcuated windows,
windows with arcuations at the
top,
in the uppermost part,
or toward the uppermost part of
the dome,
to add additional light into
the system.
And you need to think of these,
by the way, as much more ornate
in antiquity than they are
today.
They would have been stuccoed
over, which you can see,
and then probably decorated
with mosaic.
So the wonderful effects of the
light coming in,
hitting the mosaic,
and then there would've been a
pool in the center,
just as there was in the
frigidarium,
around which people could sit.
It would've been a quite
spectacular space.
And just a few more views,
to end with today.
This one up here,
which of course is the
frigidarium at Pompeii,
to show you where all of this
begins.
These two views are of the
Temple of Mercury at Baia.
And this one,
of course, of the Pantheon,
which is where we're headed.
But I think these in particular
of the Temple of Mercury at Baia
again give you a sense of the
way in which light not only
flows into this system--
again, imagine it on mosaic
ceiling and mosaic walls;
spectacular effects,
the way it would have glittered
in the light.
But look especially at the way
the shapes that are formed on
the water that would have been
in the pool down below.
It's exactly the same sort of
sense that you get when you walk
into the Pantheon today,
which also makes circles on the
floor of the pavement.
So we're going to again return
to these kinds of issues next
week.
I just wanted you to be aware
of this intermediate step
between the frigidaria of
Pompeii and some of the
buildings that we're going to be
looking at in the next couple of
weeks.
Take care.
Thank you, and Happy
Valentine's Day.